energy drinks will help you live forever
all right maybe not exactly but worms
mice and monkeys have been slamming a
common energy drink ingredient to slow
aging the amino acid taurine that's in
those 17 cans on your desk was
supplemented in the diets of a range of
animals when given to middle-aged
nematodes their lifespan increased by 10
to 23 percent and wild mice lived 10 to
12 percent longer six months of taurine
supplementation and rhesus macaques
improved their bone health metabolic
processes and immune systems taurine has
been added to baby formula since the
1980s and it does fuel gut microbes but
researchers in the journal science
caution that we need human clinical
trials on taurine to know whether it's a
lifesaver or just not worth the risk but
if taurine is shown to extend the human
lifespan gamers are gonna live forever
Vsauce one story down seven to go this
is mind blow let's open a fake Leaf Fuel
Factory an artificial Leaf can produce
ethanol from carbon dioxide sunlight and
water photosynthesis converts light
energy to chemical energy that can fuel
plants so how can we get the fuel we
need with a similar process researchers
at Cambridge University used a
photoelectrochemical operation with a
cell containing semiconducting
photoelectrodes that absorb sunlight and
generate electricity which drives a
chemical reaction that produces equal
amounts of propanol and ethanol the
artificial Leaf is just five millimeters
on each side and produces fuel in
microliters and once that could get
Scaled up it's way better than waiting
around for fossils to happen but uh
we've got a ways to go on that front
send in the robot Cavalry we make a big
deal about what robots can do but to do
what they need to know where they are
humans can look around scan an
environment and communicate the
situation to others and now the slam
system helps robot let's do it too slam
stands for simultaneous localization and
mapping an MIT roboticist developed the
Chimera multi-system so teams of robots
could distribute mapping
responsibilities amongst themselves and
then communicate the results to each
other to build highly accurate Maps
eventually an array of robot
cartographers could uh map everything
except this 71 percent of earth's
surface covered by the terrifying
unexplored depths of the oceans for now
it turns out Greeks are a lot older than
we thought fossil's 200 kilometers south
of Athens have revealed that our human
ancestors in Greece are a full 250
000 years older than previously believed
a joint excavation by the Hellenic
Ministry of culture and sports and the
American School of classical studies
identified several sites in the
megalopolis Basin that mapped human
activity including the site kyprusia 4
which contains stone tools and Bones
from hippos rhinos and elephants from
the lower Paleolithic Era the basin's
unique paleo environment made it a safe
harbor in the Ice Age and kypuracia 4
reveals hominin activity that's 700 000
years old when it was probably too cold
to survive in more Northern climates the
excavation shows promise of unlocking
more about our ancestors in the middle
of the pleistene but we're still about
150 million years removed from sliding
off the tail of a brontosaurus please
like this video and let me tell you
about protecting your browser with
guardio the sponsor of this mind blow I
added guardio as a first line of defense
for browsing on Chrome and immediately
found out I've had four data leaks that
compromised basically all of my personal
information browsers store messages
banking info passwords addresses and
more and that's where guardio comes in
the extension detects threats before
they reach your browser unlike
traditional solutions that only remove
them after they're already on your
device it detects and blocks phishing
attempts no matter the source flux
malicious downloads blocks fake and
malicious sites alerts you once a
malicious email bypasses your spam
folder and is trusted by over a million
users get a clean and secure browsing
experience at guard.io
vsauce2 Link in the description so scan
your browser for threats for free by
going to guard.io vsauce2 and installing
the extension you'll get a seven day
free trial and 20 off your subscription
and one guardio account covers five
users at no extra cost we just
discovered the oldest organic molecules
in the known universe Jimmy dubs aka the
James Webb Space Telescope discovered
the organic materials that are more than
12 billion light years away it continues
to deliver amazing images that tell us
more about the universe and this time
it's a collection of polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons we see them here on Earth
in wildfires Canada recently sent a
bunch of pahs to New York City but in
space they might be a building block to
forming Stars an international team of
scientists were able to see the
molecules because of gravitational
lensing the alignment of two galaxies
from Earth's perspective which they call
Nature's magnifying glass they focus on
spt-041847 at a distance of 12.3 billion
light years equivalent to when Earth was
around 10 percent of its current age
organic molecules are necessary for the
earliest forms of life but I'm still
waiting to see some aliens guys please
thank you and now for some deep sleep
news think of inducing torpor like
freezing Han Solo and Carbonite a sort
of hibernation in which metabolic
functions slow way down and a body can
survive in lower temperature temporarily
shutting down a living body safely has
been an element of Science Fiction for a
reason but now a team of biomedical
engineers at Washington University have
used ultrasound on Mouse brains to
activate a torfer-like state by
subjecting the hypothalamus pre-optic
area to Ultrasound waves mice entered a
state of hypothermia and hypometabolism
lasting more than 24 hours over 60 years
ago this idea was floated so astronauts
could have an easier time with space
travel but it could also slow down
bodies during the treatment of acute
events like heart attacks so yeah a few
decades from now your augmented reality
headset might detect your abnormal heart
rhythm and zap you into a cold sleep as
you wait for the Emergency drones to
arrive one can only hope for finally one
step closer to astronaut Dr Octopus a
spacesuit that allows free safe movement
outside a vehicle is great but one that
gives you more than two hands and two
arms is even better three researchers at
mit's diabolar laboratory for
information systems have designed a
spacesuit with supernumerary limbs
really an additional set of arms they
can help brace astronauts against forces
within microgravity and attenuate the
astronaut's Mass these combine to
stabilize the astronaut and make outside
missions safer also it just looks really
cool glowing ancient sword alert
archaeologists and Bavaria have
uncovered a sword from the 14th century
BC that's so well preserved that its
blade still shines the bronze of its
octagonal Hilt has turned green from its
copper oxidizing but the sword is in
amazing condition it was buried with a
man woman and child and its pristine
State suggests it may have been
ceremonial but I like to think it was
used to slay Skeletor and now
introducing the compact disc in 1982 and
that's it the biggest revolution in the
recording industry since the invention
of the long-playing gramophone record
but this is now ordinary disc just 12
centimeters in diameter the music is
recorded onto it digitally and there's
no needle being dragged through a Groove
that information is being read by a
laser light
[Music]